الشحن الأجنبي حوالي أكثر من
ثلاثة بالمائة من انبعاثات غازات الدفيئة العالمية
في عام 2021، على سبيل المثال، ينبعث الشحن
حوالي 700 مليون طن متري من ثاني أكسيد الكربون
وهو ما يمثل حوالي ثلث
الانبعاثات المحلية في الهند، وإذا
أردنا أن نجعل الشحن العالمي نوعًا من
حق الدولة  في قائمة أكبر
الانبعاثات العالمية، ستحتل
المركز السادس، مما يوضح لك مدى
أهمية هذا الأمر، ولهذا السبب
وضعت المنظمة البحرية الدولية أو المنظمة البحرية الدولية قواعد جديدة
لصناعة الشحن لخفض
انبعاثات الكربون وتقليل تلوث الهواء
بينما يمكن للبراكين أن تطلق  بعض
المواد الكيميائية التي تسبب الأمطار الحمضية تأتي في معظمها
من النشاط البشري وحرق
الوقود الأحفوري الذي يطلق أكسيد النيتروجين وثاني
أكسيد الكبريت في الهواء،
لذلك في عام 2020 قدمت المنظمة البحرية الدولية قاعدة
تخفض المستوى المقبول للكبريت
في النفط البحري من ثلاثة ونصف.
في المائة إلى 0.5 في المائة
للمساعدة في تحقيق هذه الأهداف الخضراء لقد توصلت
جامعة الملك عبد الله للعلوم
والتكنولوجيا إلى حل، والأمر
كله يتعلق بإنشاء
وقود نظيف ومستدام للشحن،
ومعي البروفيسور ويليام روبرتس
وأستطيع أن أرى أنني أستطيع ذلك  رائحة الوقود هي كما
تعلم
متغلغلة، نعم، هل قمت بفك الكود؟ نحن نعمل على
عملية لإزالة الكبريت من زيت الوقود الثقيل
للنقل البحري، لذا فإن
الهدف هو أن نكون قادرين على الوصول إلى
لائحة المنظمة البحرية الدولية لعام 2020 التي تضع  الحد الأقصى
لانبعاثات الكبريت ومن ثم يمكنك إما
سحبه من عادم غاز المداخن
أو سحبه من الوقود. بدأ هذا المشروع منذ
أربع سنوات، وهو عبارة عن
شراكة مع شركة النفط السعودية التي يقع مقرها في أرامكو،
ملخص ليو للبروفيسور روبرت
وفريقه  يتعلق الأمر بإيجاد
حل مستدام لاستخدام أجهزة غسل الغاز
وجعلها أيضًا صديقة للبيئة من حيث التكلفة.
أجهزة غسل الغاز عبارة عن نظام تنظيف يتم
وضعه على السفن لإزالة
أكاسيد الكبريت المنهوبة من عادم السفينة،
لذا فإن الهدف الأساسي للأستاذ هو محاولة
إزالة الكبريت بشكل صحيح من  الوقود
وعدم استخدام المرشحات وعدم استخدام
أجهزة غسل الغاز على متن السفينة، نعم، لذلك تستخدم نهجًا أرضيًا
منخفض التكلفة وعالي الكفاءة،
وهذا أخضر،
لذا فأنت تستخدم الكبريت لشيء
تعرف أنه صحيح حتى لا ينتهي به الأمر
في  الغلاف الجوي أو في المحيط إذا
كنت تستخدم جهاز غسل الغاز، لذا دعني أسألك
نعم، ما هي نسبة الكبريت التي
يمكنك بالفعل تقليلها
وإزالتها من الوقود الذي تعمل
به بحيث يكون زيت الوقود عالي الكبريت
حوالي 3.5 بالمائة
ويمكننا أن نصل إلى أقل من 0.5
بالمائة، وهذه هي لائحة المنظمة البحرية الدولية.
هذه الطريقة لإزالة الكبريت ليست
جديدة، فهي موجودة منذ عدة سنوات
ويحاول البروفيسور روبرت وفريقه
إزالة الكبريت على نطاق واسع وأكثر فعالية من حيث
التكلفة هناك.  يوجد
الآن 55000 سفينة في المحيط، 800
منها تعمل بالغاز الطبيعي المسال،
لذا فإن البنية التحتية هائلة
ولن تتمكن من استبدالها
لأن ذلك يتطلب تكلفة هائلة
وعقوبات على الطاقة، لذا فمن الأفضل
تعديلها  ما لديك من محاولة
استبدال نعم تماما